mourad vit le rêve américain
un an après son arrivée aux états unis
en tant que réfugiés irakiens il a
réussi à ouvrir son propre commerce géré
bâti ma vie dit il je me sens chez moi
vivre en arabe
à dearborn au michigan a facilité son
intégration en ça nous aide énormément
affirme-t-il la barrière culturelle
n'existe pas
la moitié des 90 milles les idents de
dearborn sont d'origine arabe
la ville a accueilli à bras ouverts des
milliers de réfugiés irakiens libanais
et syriens au fil des ans et sept mois
ce qui a récemment reçu la visite d'une
délégation du gouvernement allemand venu
voir comment l'intégration dans la
société américaine fonctionné a dit au
bois il s'agit créer un pont entre le
passé des réfugiés et leur nouvelle
réalité dit il
nous pouvons aider les réfugiés a trouvé
des services de toutes sortes dans leur
langue
le secret c'est d'être patient
ajoute-t-il
ça peut prendre plus d'un an avant que
les réfugiés soient prêts à contribuer à
notre société
malgré cette longue histoire
d'immigration arables le gouverneur
républicain du michigan a été un des
premiers à stopper l'accueil de réfugiés
syriens
après les attentats de paris je ne suis
pas certain que notre processus de
vérification des antécédents des
réfugiés soit à point a fait recette en
des réfugiés pourrait bien s'avérer être
des terroristes dit celui-ci qui sait
peut-être au nom au wat rapide brain ces
gens ne comprennent pas comment les
réfugiés ont aidé la revitalisation de
notre communauté répond l'organisme des
dalles intégration access imad abou
mourad lui reste loin de ce débat il dit
qu'il veut tout donner pour sa terre
d'accueil qui offre aussi un avenir
meilleur à son fils et si philippe
leblanc radio canada et au bois